ايضا الصور للقصف وتشاهد اعمده النيران
تتصاعد من هذه السياره المستهدفه والان
اخراج الجثث ايضا من هذه السياره
المستهدفه بقصف بالطيران المسير الامريكي
على ما وصفه مسؤول في البنتاغون للجزيره
بانه هدف عالي القيمه وتحدثت منصات
ومحطات محليه عراقيه عن ابو باقر
الساعدي
وهو احد قيادات على الاقل هو احد
قيادات كتائب حزب الله العراقي التي كانت
قد اعلنت وقف هجماتها على القوات
الامريكيه والتي كانت هذه الهجمات قد بدات
بالفعل بعد ردا على الحرب الاسرائيليه على
قطاع
[تصفيق]
غزر طلعوها طلعوها
وهذه صور اخرى ايضا من بغداد من موقع
الهجوم لهتافات
شبان العراقين يحتجون على هذا الهج بطيران
المسير الامريكي على سياره يقال انها تقل
هدفا عالي القيمه وفق تعبير مسؤول امريكي
للجزيره
h